Speaker 1: Let's go next to. Why don't we go to
Bobby from Jersey? Bobby, welcome to the show.
Speaker 2: Hello? David, could you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Okay. My question is, is that what
do you think drives people to arrive at their
political conclusions? Do you think it's more of
a biological or environmental reasons that make
the debate them draw to that specific conclusion?
Speaker 1: So there's a couple different things
going on here. This is a great question.
One, in general, people's political views
do mirror those of their parents and the community
they were raised in and the people they were
raised around. So there is no question that there
is lots of people who if you put them in a liberal
family in Connecticut, they're likely to end
up liberal. If you put them in a conservative
family in Arkansas, they're more likely to end up
conservative. So one part of it is the environment
you grow up around. At the same time, there
are some pretty good peer reviewed studies into
the differences in brains between left and
right wingers, and it's believed that right
wingers have stronger sort of like disgust
reactions and fear reactions, and that that
also appears to be a factor. So it's kind of a
boring answer, but it appears to be sort of like
a combination of all of these different things.
Speaker 2: So that was actually kind of the
answer I was looking for because I've run
into stuff like that and I noticed many of
the different personality traits between
me and many of my conservative colleagues.
Speaker 1: Oh, what do you get?
What's an example? What's a trait
you notice in your conservative colleagues?
Speaker 2: Like a lot of them tend to be very
aggressive. They tend to always want more.
They always. They're very status obsessed.
Very hard to say. Interesting. Yeah. So I that's
that's something I've noticed. Thank you, David.
Speaker 1: All right. There's Bobby from
Jersey with a nice, nice question. That's
a good topic. Yeah, there's there's a lot of
science around that, and not everybody sort of,
like, accepts or likes it or agrees with the
science, but it's pretty interesting stuff.